un trágico récord el estado se enfrenta
a su segunda ola de calor en pocas
semanas con temperaturas récord que
junto con los fuertes vientos forman el
clima ideal para la propagación de la
veintena de incendios activos comenzó y
se fue empujando hacia el este y luego
hacia el norte el viento del oeste hoy
se movió hacia el sur por lo que los
vientos fueron dramáticamente
inconsistentes
entonces el domingo más de 200 personas
que se encontraban en una zona de
acampada fueron evacuadas en
helicópteros militares en la sierra de
california dos personas están gravemente
heridas y otras diez sufrieron heridas
moderadas debido a las llamas del cric
fire uno de los focos más potentes las
autoridades emitieron órdenes de
desalojo a las comunidades montañosas
después de que 30 casas quedaran
destruidas en un poblado del norte del
estado con temperaturas sofocantes más
de 14.800 exhaustos bomberos se
enfrentan a 23 grandes incendios que han
llevado al cierre de bosques naturales
como el de san bernardino
la situación que tenemos ahora mismo es
de amenaza de la vida con el pronóstico
del tiempo que tenemos para los próximos
tres días
desde el pasado 14 de agosto se han
registrado más de 900 incendios
forestales en california
muchos debidos a las tormentas
eléctricas más de 8 personas han muerto
a consecuencia de los fuegos y más de
3000 estructuras han sido calcinadas